[موسيقى]
انا محمد الغربي فنان واستاذ عبد العالم
الموسيقى
بتونس انا وخويا بشير توام معناتها نكونوا
ديو هو يعزف عود وانا نعزف
[موسيقى]
كمنجه بدينا من صغار شاركنا في عديد
التظاهرات تحصلنا على عديد الجوائز
الوطنيه والجويه ثم بعدين انتقلنا الى
مرحله يعني جامعيه مارسنا دراستنا
الجامعيه واحترف الموسيقى
[موسيقى]
اكاديميا نطلعوا باش نخلي بصمه في
الموسيقى الاتيه العربيه وديما زد نطلعوا
باش نوصلها الموسيقى الاليه ذ للمواطن
العربي العادي لكن من
خلال التوام اللي عننا ما نقولوا الطبيعيه
ثم التوام الموسيقيه حاولنا نكونوا يعني
اسلوب وفلسفه جديده في التعبير به الالتين
في مجال الموسيقى
الالت شنو تحب
[موسيقى]
تسمع قالتلي زين
الزين
[موسيقى]
فنان نعرفوا اللي عنده عائله عنده بيئه
حاضنه ترعرع فيها يعني وكبر فيها الحمد
لله احنا جينا في عائله فنيه ثقافيه
تحصلنا على التانيت الذهبي في 2010 اللي
هو الجائزه الاولى في الوطن العربي في
العود ثم الجائزه الثانيه في المجموعات
الموسيقيه على المستوى العربي والافريقي
عام 2015 والجائزه الثالثه على المستوى
العالمي في اوزبكستان مهرجان مقام كل ما
هو مختلف يستطيع ان يتعايش في محبه وفي
سلم وفي ابداع يعني هذه رساله الاخوين او
التوام الغربي في عالم الموسيقى الحياه هي
متفقه مع الموسيقى في جوهرها وفي باطنها
ولا يمكن ان توجد حياه بدون موسيقى
الموسيقى هي الفعل هي الفيزياء هي الصوت
هي الاقا هي الحياه في
[موسيقى]
نها